cette montée de la violence et c'est ce
que nous faisons alors c'est un peu trop
simple de dire c'est tel ou tel facteur
social qui a provoquer les choses et il
y a une sorte de déterminisme qui fait
de fatalité qui fait que les hommes ne
seraient pas libres en réalité les
hommes sont libres et chacun est
responsable de lui-même le mot de
responsabilité est essentiel vous tenez
à la liberté monsieur Hernu comme nous
tous ici et bien il n'y a pas de liberté
sans responsabilité chaque homme est
responsable de ses actes
et ces actes ont des conséquences qu'il
faut qu'il assume c'est cela l'essentiel
de la vie en commun et bien vous ne
pouvez pas admettre que l'on peut lutter
contre l'insécurité si en même temps
vous dites c'est la faute à la société
donc l' divividu n peut rien vra mais
enfin dire tout de même sur le nombre
des détenus on voit que la moitié des
42667 détenus que nous avons
actuellement au moins de 25 ans et que
65 % ont entre 18 et 30 ans alors
écé il
A00 dans des pris qui son fait pour0000
mois vous poser la
question est-ce que vous avez est-ce que
nous avons n société actuellementt
moderne une réponse à la délinquant
juvénil dire
que prévention d'un côté répression de
l'autre oui bien sûr est-ce que nous
avons une réponse à ça est-ce que il pas
une seule réponse ce n'est pas si simple
que ça citer le rapport réponse à la
violence que les membres du Comité
d'études sur la violence et moi-même
nous avons élaboré pendant 15 mois avant
même que je devienne garde vaisseau et
ce rapport n'est pas un rapport
simpliste il énumère beaucoup de
facteurs de la violence mais il faut
tout même pas oublier l'essentiel ce que
la violence est dans l'homme depuis que
l'homme est né sur la terre il est
violent et je dirais non seulement
l'homme au sens l'être humain mais
l'homme malâ et ce n'est n'est pas un
hasard si l'on constate qu'il y a 10
fois plus de délinquants hommes que de
délinquant femmes 10 fois plus de
criminel hommes que de criminel femmes
10 fois plus même davantage d'hommes que
de femmes en prison l'homme est agressif
naturellement il l'a toujours
été l'important c'est d'arriver à
maîtriser et à contrôler cette
agressivité cette violence de façon
qu'elle n'aille pas trop loin il faut
pas s'imaginer qu'on la supprimera parce
que est en nous elle est fondamentale
elle est naturelle je ne vous réponds
pas monsieur le ministre mais il y a un
point qu'on a un peu je trouve écarté
rapidement et qui est quand même un
début de réponse à tout ce que nous
disons c'est l'ilotage hein et je je
veux dire ici je pense pas qu'il y ait
quelqu'un qui soit pas de cet avis à
quel point c'est attendu partout mon
alors c'est l'OF de Colon semble-t-il
tout le mondeage à l'anglaise des gens
qui habitent sur place que les polici
veulentabiter sur place alors c'est
c'est l're de colon et monsieur le
ministre r pourquoi vous en faites pas
davantage pilotage d'abord il y a
actuellement 6000 policiers qui sont
affectés à des tâches exclusives
d'ilotage l'augmentation a été de 30 %
en 1 an ces tilotage revait diverses
formes ce sont les unités mobiles de
sécurité les unités légères de sécurité
et il y a l'ilotage à pied qui
d'ailleurs vient pour une part de ces
unités mobotage monsieur le ministre les
unités mobiles c'est pas de l'ilotage ce
qui est ce qui est de l'ilotage ce qui
est de la présence c'est en tout cas le
bureau de police qui se trouve dans la
cité des 4000 où l'antenne de la brigade
des mineurs qui s'y trouve également
mais de jour alors que le bureau de
police est ouvert de jour et de nuit
pasilotage monsieur Valbon pourquoi
c'est pas parce que les unité mobiles
viennent dans un quartier pour quelques
instants et puis et puis repartent ce
que nous souhaitons et c'est en ce sens
que les mesures sont en même temps
politiques et et de police c'estd que
quand je disais tout à l'heure rendre
les gens plus responsables faire de
telle sorte que dans un quartier où le
lilotage est pratiqué les gens leurs
associations les habitants euh se
sentent concernés c'est-àdire que il ils
se s'autogèrent en quelque sorte je
crois que ça serait euh bien de placer
le mot autogestion à cet endroit-là et
dans ce domaine intervenant des
policiers lié à la population vivant
avec elle connu de la population pouvant
intervenir lorsque cette population les
réclame je crois qu'il y aurait
coïncidence alors ça n'est pas l'offre
de Colon je crois que l'ilotage tout
seul ça n'est pas suffisant
responsabiliser les gens dans un
quartier c'est ce que nous voulons faire
nous AES les communist c'est à cela que
nous travaillons dans les conditions
actuelles mais il faut les deux et il
faut que vous monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur vous nous écoutiez que vous
m'écoutiez lorsque je suis allé vous
trouver pour vous dire voilà ce qu'il
faudrait faire en scène Saint- sécurité
monsie monsieur vous voulez dire quelque
chose oui moi je voudrais dire quelque
chose c'est que je crois qu'il est
parfaitement injuste de ne pas
reconnaître les progrès considérables
qui ont été faits grâce à la présence de
Monsieur Bonet à ce ministère à la fois
par les effectifs à la fois par la
création des écoles à la fois par la
modernisation des moyens et je crois que
ça va dans le bon sens et je voudrais en
rendre hommage ceci étant dit n'oublions
pas que dans moyens il y en a beaucoup
d'autres est-ce que vous savez par
exemple que d'abord dire au niveau du
citoyen leur apprendre à ne pas faire
d'imprudence 1/ers des automobilistes
laissent les clés sur la voiture alors
faut quand même pas exagérer c'est une
tentation vraiment excessive pour des
jeunes qui n'ont pas d'auto est-ce que
vous savez que 50 % des gens pour aller
faire une petite course laissent leurs
portes ouvertes alors il y a des gens
qui rentrent est-ce que vous pensez pas
que l'information permanente au niveau
par exemple des personnes âgées a déjà
porté ses fruits est-ce que vous ne
croyez pas également qu'il faut
apprendre aux gens un peu à se garantir
on a parlé tout à l'heure du blindage
mais il y a bien d'autres moyens
également les alarmes les moyens de
défense moi ce que je voudrais vous dire
Monsieur le Ministre furissante
d'ailleurs ce que je voudrais vous dire
Monsieur le Ministre c'est qu'il y a un
problème de société de prévention et de
sécurité il faudrait à tout prix qu'à
travers une loi on arrive à mieux les
définir s'agit pas de faire une police
parallèle parce qu'elle a bien une elle
a une mission qui va alléger celle de
votre police au fond nous cherchons à ce
que la police fasse son métier et nous
essayons de l'aider or ici ces sociétés
de prévention de sécurité qui naissent
un peu partout sans règles définies ça
devient un danger il faut donc définir
comment elles seront faites quelles
seront leurs missions quels seront leurs
critères c'est absolument indispensable
et vous aurez d'un seul coup pour ceux
qui le souhaiteront les commerçants les
banques les grands ensembles des moyens
supplémentaires d'assurer la sécurité et
je dirais que je m'excuse mais les
maires nous nous restons pas les bras
croisés dev le problème de la jeunesse
c'est vrai que le chômage est un drame
et que c'est peut-être aujourd'hui le
péché capital de notre société des
jeunes qui arrivent et qui disent B dès
que je sors de l'école je deviens
chômeur c'est épouvantable ça on ne peut
pas accepter ça et très certainement il
va falloir en prendre des moyens bon
mais ceci étant dit sur le plan des
mairies mais on fait beaucoup on fait
beaucoup on fait beaucoup non seulement
en créant des maisons de jeûne des
foyers de jeûne en mettant des
éducateurs que nous payons mais en
essayant de multiplier les moyens
d'intéresser les jeunes à quelque chose
et en évitant en en espérant qu'ils ne
tomberont pas dans la drogue dans le vol
qu'ils appellent la débrouillardise et
bien je pense que ça il fallait quand
même le dire et nous pouvons être tous
d'accord là-dessus il y a cette jeunesse
qui n'est pas plus mauvaise qu'une autre
finalement mais qui est plus t que les
autres aujourd'hui et qui est un peu
plus déboussolé parce qu'elle se trouve
dans un cadre de vie dans une société
qui se bouleverse qui se transforme et
don ne saisit pas vers quoi elle va
c'est ça le drame vous donne la
transition pour parler probablement d'un
des sujets les plus important de cette
émission c'est-à-dire les jeunes et puis
la délinquence des jeunes et puis
qu'est-ce qu'on fait des jeunes
délinquants alors Monsieur Hern je crois
que vous avez demandé la parole sur ce
sujet oui je suis tout à fait d'accord
sur un point c'est que les maires font
beaucoup souvent ailleurs au prix
d'augmentation de leur budget avec tout
ce que ça représente pour les
populations mais il est bien évident que
installer un équipement sportif moi par
exemple nous installons avec notre adent
au sport dans des quartiers de la ville
des clubs de boxe pour les jeunes et
monsieur le ministre vous parlez de la
violence mais ils ont un moyen là de le
dépenser et de rentrer chez eux le club
de catch le club de judo nous les stades
tout cela fait partie il faut aussi qu'à
l'école on redonne le sens civile
l'éducation civique qu'on réapprenne ce
que c'est l'histoire de notre pays et
qu'on ne le laisse pas tomber parce que
tout ça fait partie de cette éducation
et aussi qu'il y ait des classes où on
apprenne le travail manuel tout ça c'est
vrai l'ilotage ce n'est pas la panassée
mais c'est bien à condition que les
îotiers ne viennent pas d'ailleurs moi
qu'est-ce que je reproche au quart de
CRS moi je dois dire que pendant le mois
d'août quand les CRS quitte villeurban
et vont sur les plages ou vont sur les
autoroutes la population villeurbanaise
est foller à l'idée qu'ils s'en vont
j'ai même dû vous le savez ça a fait
quelques bruit substituer créer une
police municipale c'est formidable mais
municip municipale j'ai maintenant 17
hommes et femmes qui qui supplaient à la
police d'État avec nos moyens mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que l'ilotage et
c'est cela que je souhaite la
concertation avec vous avec le
représentant des forces de police qu'il
faut que les maires il participent qu' a
des réunions mensuelles c'est parce que
moi tous les malfrat villeurbane ils
savent qu'à 17h les îotiers rentrent
chez eux il n'y a pas d'équipe de nuit
ils ne sont pas dans le quartier pardon
pardon il y a une brigade spéciale de
nuit à Lyon que j'ai vu l'autre jour je
l'ai même
vban oui mais vous vous faites partie de
la circonscription de Lyon je vous l'
tout à l' pas du tout pas du tout je
vais vous expliquer de quelle
circonscription je fais partie puisque
là je vois que vous ne le savez pas
j'appartiens au 4e secteur de police le
4e secteur de la circonscription de Lyon
non mais si non alors c'est pas à moi
que vous allez apprendre ça voulez
voulez pas problème la
fin cl Dex le 4 le 4è secteur comprend
villeorbane dessine bronv il comprend un
certain nombre de communes de l'Est de
Lyon et il comprend il comprend quelque
chose comme 250000 habit mais je en ce
qui concerne la délinquant moi ce que je
souhaite des jeunes c'est que Monsieur
Douchin qui est mon témoin vous
l'écoutiez un moment il habite la
cénémarne il est l'ancien sec général du
Syndicat national des personnels de
l'éducation surveillé il appartient à la
Fédération de l'éducation nationale il
est éducateur et éducateur personnel
aussi puisquil est perd 6 enfantson si
je comprends bien monsieur Douchin c'est
ça monsieur Douchin est une personne qui
s'occupe des
délinquants et qui tente de les
réinsérer dans le milieu social come
c'est ça comme j'ai reçu des lettres
comme vous tous de protestation je vous
vois arriver avec des papiers monsieur
vous allez pas nous faire un discours
non non absolument pas simplement ma
mémoire PE
quelques chiffres que je voudrais citer
et bien nous vous écoutons je voulais
simplement je voulais simplement
souligner ce soir que les éducateurs du
ministère de la justice dont je fais
partie qui ont pour mission précisément
de travailler en étroite liaison avec
les juges des enfants et bien ces
éducateurs sont fort inquiets ils sont
fort inquiets parce que bien sûr nous le
soulignons tous ici les problèmes ne
sont pas simple mais la la délinquance
augmentant nous considérons nous
constatons que les moyens qui sont mis à
notre disposition eux ne n'augmentent
pas en conséquence nous parlions tout à
l'heure il y a et fort longuement des
moyens mis à la disposition de la Police
nous voyons la nos jeunes traduit devant
les tribunaux pour
enfant plus que jamais placé en prison
beaucoup plus que par le passé et nous
considérons que si malheureusement
effectivement il y a un certain nombre
de cas où il est impossible
effectivement de faire autrement c'est
pour nous je pense le le contraire de ce
qu'il faudrait faire parce que la prison
c'est comment dire une on a tout à
l'heure on a dit l'école du crime mais
je pense que malheureusement depuis
depuis 2 ans
et bien ce ce phénomène il s'accentue je
croyais que le ministre de la Justice
avait publié une circulaire je la
retrouver dans dans laquelle il mettait
en garde contre l'emprisonnement des
jeunes vous aviez pas publié quelque
chose comme ça ou oui 2 novembre 78 on
le laisse terminer et je réponds oui
allez-y est-ce que je peux préciser une
chose moi pour éclaircir téléspectateur
c'est que en 1979 il y a eu 64000000
jugements concernant les mineurs et que
sur ces 64000 jugements il y a eu qu
4000 décisions de prison en ferme et
10000 décisions de prison avec surcis
donc ça éclaire un petit peu le ceci
pour les affaires jugées bien ce que je
voudrais dire c'est que ce qui nous
inquiète actuellement dans le processus
qui semble engager et qui ne semble pas
conforme à la loi la loi je le rappelle
prévoit c'est l'ordonnance du 2 février
45 pour les jeunes de moins de 18 ans
que l'on pourvoit à l'éducation qui
n'ont pas reçu et non pas qu'on les
mette en prison et prioritairement
l'éducation
et il faut faire les magistrats pour
enfants de par ce texte sont tenus
d'épuiser toutes les possibilités
d'éducation avant de recourir à la à la
sanction pénale et je dois dire que
depuis depuis 2 ans et bien c'est il y a
un processus qui est très alarmant et
notamment pour les plus jeunes ce
précisément moins de 16 ans qui faisait
l'objet de la circulaire du 2 novembre
78 de Monsieur legarde Dessau alors
j'indique ce chiffre parce que ça nous
paraît EXM grave monsieur vous parant
absolument absolument en
1979 il y a eu
4308 enfant de en placé en détention
provisoire donc avant jugement et en 198
ce chiffre AB bondi à plus de
6000 c'est pour nous un c'est un
accroissement sans précédent dans les 5
dans les 5 années précédentes il
tournait autour de 4000 et cela ne
traduit absolument pas une augmentation
consécutive des délits commis par ces
enfants et pourquoi pourquoi nous nous
alarmons parce que parmi ces jeunes les
moins de 16 ans sont en fort grand
nombre et la catégorie des moins de 16
ans a même purement et simplement doublé
entre 79 et 80 vous alliez vite monsieur
parce que vous êtes en train d'épuiser
le temps de parole de Monsieur Hernu
j'entends bien mais alors je v minute au
total très bien je voudrais dire que
donc cette prise sé jour en prison pour
ces jeunes est particulièrement
désastreux dans les circonstances
actuelles et que c'est une solution qui
est plus dangereuse qu'utile dans la
mesure où plus et cela ça c'est c'est
absolument certain depuis plus de 20 ans
je l'ai constaté bien souvent au niveau
des jeunes dont je m'occupe plus on va
jeune en prison plus on en reste marqué
et surtout plus on y retourne et c'est
ça n'est en aucun cas un coup d'arrêt
qui est donner à ses comportements il
faut s'attaquer aux causes et donc il ne
s'agit pas là de traiter le symptôme il
faut absolument éviter de placer ces
jeunes dans des pourrissoires que sont
les prisons actuelles je prends deux
exemples le surpeuplement actuel des
prisons on l'a souligné tout à l'heure
27000 places 42000 détenus et bien ces
mineurs ces enfants quelquefois de moins
de 16 ans 14 et 15 ans il est impossible
d'assurer leur hébergement de dans des
cellules isolées moyen en quoi il se
trouve m les plus âgés et quelquefois il
se passent des incidents fort fort
regrettables pour ne pas dire fort grave
des violences physiques absolument à la
prison de rillon je suis désolé je vais
être obligé de vous arrêter oui mais
écoutez alors là je pense monsieur
monsieur le Président de la République
est allé au début de son SEP à la prison
Saint-Paul puisque ne voulez pas
entendre ce qui se passe à la prison de
Ron à la prison Saint-Paul le jour où il
y est allé en 1960 en 1974 il y avait 8
mineurs aujourd'hui il y en a 57 pardon
il y en a 47 il y en avait 57 et dans
quoi dans 14 cellules monsieur le
Président de la République s'il allait
aujourd'hui la prison Saint- paaul pour
serrer la main d'un enfant en prison il
devrait enchamber une paillasse parce
qu'ils sont quatre par par c'est lon
c'est à lon alors ce que ce que nous
proposons je suis désolé monsieur vous
n'avez plus la parole vous avez épisé
faut modifier la loi pour les moin de 16
an entendu vous permettez Monsieur
ministre de vous poser une question qui
un rapport naturellement avec ce qui
vient d'être dit notre impression c'est
que effectivement la prison n'est pas
très adapté au mineurs mais d'un autre
côté c'est dans la totale liberté des un
certain nombre de mineurs qui ou de ou
de non mineurs enfin 18 30 ans dirais-je
les deux jeunes qui commettent des
délits et qui récidivent n'est pas non
plus possible on peut pas être aussi
laxiste est-ce qu'il ne manque pas un
espace dans dans dans dans dans vos
préoccupations quelque chose pour les
jeunes spécialement pour cette catégorie
pénale quelque chose qui évite les
inconvénients que l'on vient de dire
etous avons tous compris de quoi il
s'agissait mais qui soit pas non plus la
liberté le laisser aller le retour comme
on l'indiquait tout à l'heure après un
délit 3 jours après dans la commune où
nous revoyons ces jeunes qui ont commis
de grave parfois des lits j'étais
attaqué dans le RER personnellement je
suis pas plus mal porté pour ça mais
enfin de jours après j'envoyis quand
même les jeunes dans la rue menargan bah
c'est pas tout à fait normal ni il
manque quelque chose oui il faut quand
même dire une chose c'est que moi je
pour dire avec Monsieur Péricard
attention c'est que notre population
trouve que la justice est trop mol et
elle dit comment ils font des coups ils
peuvent recommencer et cetera il faut
quand même tenir compte quand même de je
dirais de cette aspiration alors il faut
traiter les jeunes bien sûr avec
beaucoup délicatesse et je rejoins que
des promiscuités sont très dangereuses
et à mon sens à supprimer mais il faut
quand même que à la faute et bien il y
ait une sanction même si elle n'est pas
cruel autrement nous sommes là dans une
pagaille épouvantable et n'importe qui
FAA n'importe quoi au moment où il n'y a
plus aucun frein moi je crois que dans
ce domaine ce que demande la population
c'est pas que les jeunes soit soit mis
dans des situations épouvantables on
voudrait en particulier qu'il puisse
avoir leur chance dans la vie c'est vrai
moi j'ai aussi monsieur Hernu amené un
de mes un de mes amis et qui s'occupe
beaucoup justement de ces problèmes
réinsertion sociale de délinquant je
vous aurais volontiers donné une minute
d'ailleurs bon il s'est occupé pendant 4
ans de la drogue et pendant ans du
problème des immigrés dont on a pas
parlé mais où la délinquence est à peu
près qu fois supérieure à la moyenne bon
d'après les chiffres que j'ai moi à
Toulon en tout cas alors à l'occasion il
pourra prendre la parole mon mon soutien
en quelque sorte mais ce que je peux
dire c'est que il faut les choses ne
sont pas si simples que ça et je rejoins
mon collègue monsieur ber en disant il
est toujours dangereux de ne pas donner
à un jeune sa chance il est toujours
dangereux ne pas sanctionner les bêtises
qu'ils font il faut faire en sorte que
la sanction ne soit pas plus grave
finalement pour ce jeûne que la bêtise
qu'il a pu faire monsieur per bien alors
je voudrais tout de même introduire un
peu de clarté euh dans dans ce débat
c'était pas clair non c'était pas clair
parce que c'était faux on partait
d'idées fausses et on partait de
chiffres faux quand vous parliez
monsieur le témoin tout à l'heure de
l'Éducation surveillée qui est donc un
membre de l'administration que
j'administre quand vous parliez de 6000
jeunes en prison et que vous parliez
d'autre part de 42000 personnes en
prison c'est un chiffre qu'on a vu ces
jours derniers dans la presse et qui
présenté comme tel est tout à fait
absurde quand on parle de statistique il
faut savoir de quoi on parle quand on
parle de moyenne il faut savoir de quoi
on parle alors ce que vous venez de dire
monsieur c'est à peu près comme si vous
disiez une femme est fidèle à son mari
une autre femme le trompe deux fois par
semaine en moyenne ces deux femmes le
trompent une fois par semaine pourquoi
parce que on ne définit pas la
statistique comme elle devrait être
sécurité liberté vous avez
6000 personnes de moins de 18 ans qui
ont été interpellés et qui ont fait
l'objet d'une décision de justice qui
est le plus souvent d'incarcération
provisoire avant
et seul pour
4 dans les procédures de flagr ça fait
6000 personnes mais on compte dans ces
ça ne fait pas 6000 personnes car on
compte dans ces
6000 ceux qui sont des récidivistes ou
qui sont inculpés pour plusieurs faits
alors chacun de ces faits forme une
décision judiciaire différente et on
disim000 mais en réalité à un moment
donné par exemple aujourd'hui 12 mars
1981 il y a moins de 900 mineurs dans
les prisons alors 900 à côté de 42000 ça
ce sont des statistiques convenables
mais 6000 à côté de 4000 c'est absurde
bien première rectification qui porte
sur les chiffres 2uxè observation c'est
6000 dans l'année bien sûr 6000n 6000
dans dans l'année qui souvent ne passe
que 2 jours et à un moment donné à un
moment précis il n'y en a que 900 et sur
ces 900 il n'y en a que 1/1è environ
moins de 90 qui sont des mineurs de 16
ans alors ça ça remet les choses à la
vraie proportion quand on parle de
statistique il fa savoir de quoi parle
deièmement autre
erreur qui est une erreur non plus de
chiffr mais de d'idée
d'analyse vous dites les jeunes pas
question d'y toucher les jeunes c'est un
pourissoir que de les mettre en prison
alors les jeunes sauf certaines prisons
dans certains cas et pour très peu de
temps sont mis dans des quartiers
différents où ils n'ont pas un véritable
régime euh de détenus comme les détenus
majeurs mais où ils sont placés en
réalité sous des responsabilité
d'éducation et ils sont soumis à une
éducation et dans toute la mesure du
possible on les entraîne à du travail
manuel et alors il y a une contradiction
dans le fait que d'une part beaucoup de
Français
s'étonne que un délinquant un criminel
soit appréhendé par la police et puis
que on le livre à la justice et qu'il
reparte chez lui plus vite que les
agents de police qui l'ont conduit au
parquet et bien vous pouvez pas à la
fois dire que la justice est tr laxiste
et dire que c'est épouvantable on met
les gens en prison il faut savoir de
quoi on parle quand vous parlez de
l'incarcération vous parlez de quelque
chose qui n'est pas souhaitable qui
n'est pas en soi souhaitable mais qui
peut dans le cas des jeunes apporter ce
que j'ai appelé un choc vous avez repris
cette
expression qu'est-ce que c'est que la
délinquance juvénile qu'est-ce que c'est
que un jeune délinquant c'est un jeune
qui a une personnalité flottante c'est
un jeune qui n'a pas été éduqué dès son
plus jeune âge à savoir la différence
entre le bien et le mal entre le permis
et le défendu il a besoin de se heurter
à la société d'avoir une réaction de la
société puisque ses parents sa famille
souvent désunis et l'école ne lui ont
pas appris la morale vous parliez
monsieur Hernu de la nécessité que
l'école apporte à l'enfant une éducation
civique et morale c'était la grande
école de de Jul ferry c'était la grande
école des instituteurs de la 3e
république depuis ses passé de mode et
beaucoup coup d'enseignants estimer
qu'il n'avaiit pas à faire de
l'instruction civique ni à faire de
l'instruction morale heureusement depuis
peus y reviennent heureusement depuis
peu ils y reviennent et heureusement ils
reconnaissent qu'il faut enseigner les
valeurs qu'il faut enseigner l'éducation
civique alors ne me dites pas que il ne
faut pas de sanction et quelle autre
sanction voulez-vous que la privation de
liberté nous ne voulons pas des
châtiments corporels il faut bien la la
privation de liberté et une privation de
liberté de courte durée est une façon
d'ouvrir les yeux sur un adolescent qui
est encore flottant qui est encore
immature sur les conséquences de ces
actes et sur la nécessité de ne pas
franchir certaines bornes la société
doit savoir punir car la société doit
indiquer les bornes à ne pas franchir
mon est-ce que vous voulez répondre à la
proposition de Monsieur Péricard parce
qu'il vous demand s'il y avait pas jeosé
une seconde si vous permettez en même
temps comme ça vous me répondrez d'un
seul C voulez-vous rappeler aux
téléspectateurs la première oui je
disais euh est-ce qu'il n'y a pas besoin
d'un espace différent vous avez répondu
d'ailleurs en partie mais enfin il
s'agissait quand même dans votre esprit
là de de jeunes récidivistes ayant quand
même étant auteur de délites très
caractérisé je pense à des jeunes moi
Ana qui sont des débutants en
particulier et je sais que d'autres
maères l'ont fait moi j'ai fait un jour
l'expérience de rendre la justice sans
vous demander la permission messieurs
c'est-à-dire de faire réparer par des
jeunes des dégâts qu'ils avaient
commisou bon et ça s'est fort bien passé
ils sont même allés au-delà des dégâts
qu'ils avaient commis en ont fait un peu
plus est-ce qu'il y a pas là quelque
chose de quand même plus plus éducatif
plus pédagogique plus souhaitable pour
le jeun qui ne s'applique pas je suis
bien d'accord avec vous à tous les cas
mais qui peut quand même s'appliquer
quelquefois et les maires sont pas de
mauvais juges sans jeu de mot pour ce
genre de chose absolument vous avez
monsie a l'air d'accord avec cette
proposition moi j'ai eu le cas avec des
gens du voyage
je leur ai fait réparer
la réparer la clôture et il y a là un
moyen effectivement mais que je vis
monsieur le ministre
courtoisens je prends la minute qu'il
me monsieur le ministre
quand vous êtes agressé et que vous
recevez un coup de PO si vous le rendez
tout de suite vous êtes en état de
légitime défense si vous le rendez au
bout de 6 mois vous devenez un agresseur
or le jeûne que l'on met dans la prison
si la sanction n'est pas immédiate mais
si il reste trop longtemps dans cette
période d'attente alors il devient
antiociété car vous savez bien que 50 %
des jeunes traités de cette façon
deviennent des récidivistes et menacent
la société de demain c'est ce qu'il faut
éviter ministre alors il vous reste
normalement plus aucun temps pour
répondre à moins que dans le cadre de la
solidarité gouvernementale que bon vous
accorde quelques minutes
supplémentaires je je je n'ai pas
profité de tout mon temps par que merci
je dois dire qu'il faut que je réponde à
un certain nombre de choses qui me sont
apparu inexact je donne aussi une minute
au ministre de la justice il a peut-être
un peu plus l'habitude et par peut-être
un peu plus vite je je vois que j'ai
encore de la réserve alors d'abord
travail manuel bien sûr le travail
manuel permet aux jeunes de se réinsérer
et de s'épanouir ça a été peut-être une
erreur pendant quelques années de
prétendre que la prolongation de la
scolarité obligatoire ça devait vouloir
dire la suppression de l'apprentissage
la suppression du travail manuel on en
est venu aujourd'hui à faire accepté par
les syndicats d'enseignants la notion
d'enseignement alterné il est très
important que le travail manuel soit une
formation qui permettent aux jeunes
d'échapper à cette sensation d'échec
qu'ils ont et quand on les laisse dans
des tâches purement scolaire purement
intellectuel et c'est exactement ce que
nous faisons pour l'éducation surveillée
et c'est ce que nous faisons pour les
établissements pénitentiaires ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que le programme de
construction des établissements
pénitentiaires qui a que j'ai retenu
pour les années les 10 années à venir
pour les années 80 90 c'est un programme
qui consiste à construire des
établissements pénitentiires avec des
ateliers avec de l'espace de manière a
permettre de travailler et de d'obtenir
une formation professionnelle alors vous
me demandez euh si je suis d'accord pour
pour le travail manuel bien sûr je suis
d'accord et et c'est l'action que nous
menons alors quand on me demande euh si
euh les les jeunes ne vont pas récidiver
après être passés entre les mains de la
justice contrairement aux chiffres que
vous avez indiqué le chiffre de 50 % de
récidive c'est pour les personnes
adultes c'est pour les majeurs mais pour
les mineurs 70 % de ceux qui passent
dans les mains de la justice ne
récidivent jamais on entend plus jamais
parler deeux seulement 30 % d'entre eux
le font et par conséquent le système que
nous avons est un système efficace alors
bien sûr rien n'est parfait bien sûr je
ne prétends pas que nous avons réglé
tous les problèmes mais ils ne sont pas
aussi graves que vous vous le dites et
surtout c'est ça l'essentiel cette loi
sécurité et liberté qui a profondément
modifié le code pénal le code de
procédure pénale est une loi qui
introduit un lien qui n'existait plus
entre l'acte criminel ou l'acte
délinquent et les conséquences
judiciaires jusque là il y avait pas de
lien pourquoi il avait-il pas de lien
vous obligé de vous arrêter parce que il
y a encore des personnes qui on de par
parce qu'il se passait trop de tempsut
que vous tiriez une conclusion là et
bien maintenant le lien étroit entre
l'acte et sa sanction a été établie et
il se justifie pleinement car il est
nécessaire pour rétablir la
responsabilité des individus dans une
société de liberté j'ai remarqué
l'impatience de monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur qui n'a pas pu répondre tout
à l'heure à ce que Monsieur Valbon
disait je crois monsieur le ministre
vous avez la parole je suis d'accord
avec Monsieur Valbon en ce qui concerne
la responsabilisation
des individus des Français en général de
même que je suis d'accord avec tout ce
qu'a dit Monsieur HX sur les précautions
nous le faisons d'ailleurs nous faisons
des séances audiovisuelles au bénéfice
des personnes âgées voici le dernier
numéro de la revue de la préfecture de
police il est consacré à des conseils
aux personnes âgées sous forme de
dessins qui sont extrêmement instructifs
c'est compréhensible c'est parfaitement
non non c'est très bien fait je t c'est
très bien fait merci euh ce que je
voudrais dire c'est que Monsieur Hernu a
parlé tout à l'heure du dédommagement en
cas de cambriolage mais c'est une
société de déresponsabilisation et que
faites-vous alors de la possibilité
qu'ont les gens de s'assurer qui leur
est ouverte et que je sache les
assurances ne faillissent pas à leur
devoirs je pas temp d'en parler mais la
police canadienne a fait des expériences
très é donante en ce genre oui alors ce
que je voulais justement vous dire c'est
que les choses ne sont ni nouvelles ni
simples elles ne sont pas nouvelles et
comme je suis près d'un académicien je c
m'aventurerai à citer boilau qui disait
déjà au 17e siècle auprès du bois le
plus funeste et le moins fréquenté Paris
apparaît presque un lieu de
sûreté ça n'est pas simple car dans ce
que vous avez dit tout à l'heure
Monsieur Le Fèvre j'ai retenu que seul
parmi les pays comparables au nôtres le
Japon et le Canada mais le Japon pour
des raisons très spéciales sur
lesquelles monsieur le garde des saau'
expliqueraiit certainement s'il en avait
la possibilité seul le Japon connaît
moins la violence que nous la République
fédérale connaît plus de violence la
Grande-Bretagne plus de violence les
États-Unis plus de violence il a
l'Italie la Hollande et la Autriche
quand même vous préférez vous
préféreriez vivre en Italie Monsieur Le
Fèvre en l'état actuel des choses vous
savez que il a certaines statistiques
qui appellent des corrections les choses
ne sont pas simples
elles ne sont pas nouvell et en tout cas
le meilleur le meilleur moyen d'aboutir
à une solution n'est certainement pas de
refuser de voter les crédits qui
permettent à la police de disposer des
moyens grâce auxquels elle pourra mener
des actions plus positives notamment
dans le sens de l'îotage j'en conviens
volontiers mais monsieur je suis désolé
mais nous allons être obligés de
conclure euh avant de passer la parole à
François cornet qui se trouve au poste
de commandement de la préfecture de
police euh une conclusion je la veux de
vous et peut-être de messieur les Mair
est-ce que vous vous engagez après la
campagne électorale si d'aventure tout
tout se passait bien pour vous à revenir
parler de ces problèmes de sécurité avec
peut-être ensemble ou peut-être
séparément mais aussi souvent que les
Français auront besoin de de connaître
vos
problèmes j'ai toujours été ouvert au
dialogue je le suis avec les
organisations syndicales dont le rôle
est bien précis elles doivent tenir le
ministre au courant je pratique une
politique de concertation avec elle en y
portant simplement une limite à savoir
que l'on doit respecter la hiérarchie la
police doit être commandée et le sera et
je suis à priori ouvert à toutes les
concertations avec mes collègues ma et
avec les journalistes monsieur Bonet
vous aviez au début de cette émission
évoqué le problème de la peine de mort
on connaît votre position on connait
celle de monsieur le garde des saau on
connaît pas nécessairement celle de ces
messieurs est-ce que vous voulez les uns
après les autres dire quelle est votre
position sur la peine de mort ma
position personnelle moi je suis pour la
peine de mort
actuellement et je pense que ça évitera
en grande partie que les gens se facee
justice même monsieur Hernu moi je ne
comprends pas qu'on puisse dire qu'on
est pour la peine de mort avec l'adverbe
actuellement on est pour ou contre
actuellement qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
puisque donc je suis contre la peine de
mort j'ajoute je vous remerci de m'avoir
invité à cette émission et le souhait
que je formule puisque vous avez demandé
un c'est que nous n'avons pas eu le
temps suffisamment de parler du problème
des jeunes et de la jeunesse délinquante
on a parlé de la police et que ce sujet
à lui seul vaudrait sûrement un débat
monsieur pricard oui la la peine de mort
fait horreur et elle me fait horreur
comme à comme à tout le monde mais
peut-être que le jour Monsieur le
Ministre où on n' pas parlé de la grande
délinquence et du grand vanditisme car
ça ne nous a pas paru être le sujet tout
à fait le plus important pour les
citoyens mais le jour où on aura réglé
comme il le faut le la présence dans les
prisons définitives des criminels des
bêtes sauvages il y en a dans notre
société c'est pas la peine de le nier et
c'est pas la peine d'essayer de dire le
contraire ce jour-là je je crois que les
mentalités évolueront vers la demande de
la suppression de la peine de mort mais
aujourd'hui si vous
aviez fait un débat à l'Assemblée je
suis un parlementaire j'aurais voté
contre l'abolition n av fait un débat et
il est ressorti qu'il n avait pas de
majorité pour voter l'abolition monsieur
Val si on fait un référendum on aurait
les mêmes résultats je je je crois que
la démonstration est faite par les les
bilans qui sont donnés en particulier
sur la grande criminalité que la peine
de mort n'a pas empêché le développement
cette criminalité on connaît la position
des communistes qui sont catégoriquement
contre la peine de mort mais moi je
voulais pas je je voulais puisqu'il me
reste encore quelques instants je
voulais parce que normalement je je
voulais parler de vie je voulais parler
de vie et pour moi prenons acte du fait
que les communistes et les socialistes
sont contre le peuple qui très
majoritairement veut le je voulais
parler de vie justement parce que je
considèrele vous donne 30 secondes
monsieur
responsable c'est ce que nous voulons
faire et c'est toute l'orientation du
plan de lutte de George Marchet merci
beaucoup alors nous allons demander
maintenant à François corn où il en est
après 1 heure dem d'émission Françis
corn oui